pendant mes chers amis un parti
politique si beaucoup plus complexe
qu'on imagine à diriger et dans la salle
alain juppé michèle alliot-marie savent
ce que je veux dire c'est pas une
succession de discours où chacun d'entre
nous ont fait des discours après on
n'entend pas ce que vous dites
ce qui vient de nous est dit est capital
nous croyons à la médecine libérale
ce qui doit impliquer que les
républicains exigent la suppression
totale du tiers payant généralisé qui
est le comble de la démagogie
le comble pourquoi au prétexte de ne pas
faire payer le patient vous conduisez un
système où le seul client du médecin
libéral sera l'assurance maladie qui
paye décide c'est donc l'assurance
maladie six mois après le tiers payant
généralisé qui imposera aux médecins le
traitement qu'il doit aux patients qui
viendra le voir et s'en sera fini de la
liberté de choix du remède par le
médecin libéral et six mois après c'est
l'assurance maladie qui vous dira le
médecin de votre quartier que vous
devrez aller voir et s'en sera fini de
la liberté de choisir son médecin c'est
tout
la médecine libérale qui est attaqué par
le tiers payant généralisé
il ne peut pas y avoir la moindre
ambiguïté sur le sujet j'ajoute que je
croyais qu'on était pour la
responsabilisation du patient
à partir du moment où on lui fait croire
que la santé n'a pas de prix qui va
responsabiliser
de la même façon que je suis contre la
vente des médicaments dans les grandes
surfaces car la stratégie des grandes
surfaces
c'est de vendre beaucoup pour vendre
moins cher
or la stratégie de santé publique c'est
justement d'arrêter de précipiter les
français vers une surconsommation
médicale c'est clair c'est simple et
c'est net sur ce qu'a dit le précédent
intervenants je souhaite que le
mouvement l'udc est à débattre d'une
chose vous ne changerez pas le modèle
social français
sans changer la démocratie française
nous nous enivre ont deux mots le
paritarisme est aujourd'hui synonyme
d'immobilisme
la première chose que je vous proposerai
c'est de supprimer le monopole de
présentation des organisations
syndicales au premier tour des élections
professionnelles
y at il un monopole pour le parti
socialiste et pour les républicains de
présentation premier tour la deuxième
chose je vous proposerai l'impossibilité
de nomination d'un délégué syndical les
délégués syndicaux doivent être élus et
non pas nommés on ne peut pas avoir un
délégué battue qui revient par la
fenêtre parce qu'il est imposée par son
organisation
et enfin la troisième chose puisque nous
sommes pour beaucoup d'entre nous
gaulliste nous croyons référendum est
bien le référendum d'entreprise doit
devenir la règle d'un dialogue social ou
c'est les salariés de l'entreprise qui
décideront avec le chef d'entreprise de
la durée du temps de travail et des
grandes décisions économiques et
sociales à prendre dans l'entreprise